JULIAN
When I become president of these United States,
I solemnly swear that the voices of every
man, woman, and baboon will be heard!
TRACE
*face*
JULIAN
Hello participating members of society, Julian
and my running mate Trace here for DNews.
Two and a half thousand years ago, some ancient
Greek people got together in Athens and decided
that not having a say in their government
was a bunch of minotaur skata.
TRACE
They decided there should be a system where
everyone, well, men at least, could have an
equal say in decision making, and they named
their new system Demokratia, which translates
to Power of the People.
JULIAN
Right on!
This has for the most part been regarded as
a step in the right direction.
Getting together, coming to a decision with
equal voices regardless of our position in
society.
It’s what separates us from monkeys.
*pause*
I’m totally kidding, monkeys do that too,
as observed by researchers from the Smithsonian
Tropical Research Institute.
TRACE
The researchers tracked the movements of a
troop of olive baboons in Kenya and found
that every member of the troop had an equal
say in where they all went.
JULIAN
This was surprising, because olive baboons
have a strong social hierarchy, and dominant
members get choice picks of food or mates
over their subordinates.
But when it comes to trekking across the savannah,
olive baboons move more like a school of fish
or flock of birds.
TRACE
In other words, no dominant members of the
troop had a disproportionate say on where
the entire gang went.
When two monkeys started moving in different
directions, the rest of the troop would decide
which to follow, and eventually the whole
group would go with the decision of the majority.
And if the two initiators picked directions
that were similar, the group would choose
a path that split the difference.
They compromised!
Americans are more stubborn than baboons!
JULIAN
That's going to knock us in the polls.
You may be thinking that, sure, group based
decision making may not be uniquely human,
but it sounds like a primate thing at most.
Well it’s not, democracy has been observed
in… bees.
I know, bees have a “queen” so you might
think that technically makes them a monarchy.
But the queen only has that title because
she gave birth to everyone in the colony,
it’s exactly how British people work.
TRACE
I would like to state on behalf of DNews that
that is not a thing.
Anyway, and like England’s constitutional
monarchy, the people, I guess in this case
bee-ple, have a say in some issues.
If the hive is deciding it’s time to choose
a new location, bees who are in the know weigh
in on the benefits of the potential sites.
Size, flower density, humidity, amount of
honey they'd have to put into the NHS…
JULIAN
The National Honey Service.
TRACE
Then the individual bees vote using the power
of dance, and once they have enough bees in
on the dance craze they brexit their old hive
and head to the site the majority picked with
the queen in tow.
JULIAN
Of course, some bees will stay behind at the
old site where new queens are hatched.
Usually the first queen to mature breaks out
and murders the other infant queens to establish
herself at the top.
TRACE
However if the original colony was very large,
then the bees will actually send out two new
groups to set up colonies, and the second
group needs a strong queen of their own.
JULIAN
In order to find out which potential queen
is most Bee-once, the workers will actually
protect all the developing queens until they
hatch, and then let them fight to the death.
You can think of it as an election.
TRACE
Of course not all animals or insects that
live in groups have democratic systems.
Wolf packs or ant colonies don’t work like
baboons or bees because their strategy seems
to be working for them so far.
JULIAN
Will democracy turn out to be the system that
leads to long term success for you in particular
and our species as a whole?
There’s only one way to find out, and that’s
to participate in it.
Sometimes in a democracy people use their
voice to elect someone who would rather the
people shut up.
To learn why this odd hybrid called an authoritarian
democracy happens, check out Trace’s video
here.
TRACE
Do you think
more than half the people are right more than
half the time, or would you vote to scrap
democracy and try something else?